thank you
yeah I'm rich Brian and I'm Joe G
last summer we became master chefs at
the ad a rising summer mansion and this
year we're teaming up with even more
chefs and special guests and asking a
few of our 80 a rising labelmates to
help us out
welcome to the feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion welcome to
the feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion yeah this
is rich Brian and we are at feast
mansion the greatest [ __ ] cooking
show in the world
and I finally kick Joe G out and I have
my friend Nikki with me stuff you guys
I'm making him super excited to be here
nice mansion so Ryan I feel like we
should do something new today
what are you thinking so like you know
we have the collaboration with Bubba guy
the head in the clouds dreams [ __ ] we do
yes okay I just realized that I don't
know how to make Bob us be neither yeah
you don't either
yeah but that sounds like a really
interesting flavor I feel like people
should really buy that I would agree and
the link down below so anyway we have
our pro here yeah Ben from boba guys you
know and I'll help
[Music]
Wow I am look at all this excited what
are we gonna do well I think I'm gonna
teach you how to make Bob alright you
guys know how to make Bobo
yes Bobo master well I mean you even
know where Bo is from is it from Taiwan
it's from Taiwan and it started in the
80s you know milk teas been around for a
really really long time but the
Taiwanese were kind of the first to like
add the tapioca balls into out really a
Bobo guys we do it a little bit
different okay
so ours is more kind of an elevated take
on you might have seen on Instagram
we're kind of famous for that
three-layered stupid macho man take em
hmm
and even for the head and clouds drink
that we made with you guys you know we
take like an Arnold Palmer but we do our
twist on it so it's like peach Palmer
with jasmine tea we're gonna do a little
bit of color with butterfly pea
it's kind of got that awesome blue
flavor your butterfly what butterfly pea
and like pa pa it's a flower
and it's a huge distinction and then we
top it with the crema that that flavor
sounds really interesting I feel like
it's something that people should I
write I think people should really buy
that what is your go-to drink anyway I
don't actually drink boba that much just
cuz I generally kind of avoid sugar
because I'm better than everybody but I
if I do get it I like Thai tea like
flavored stuff I'll have like you know
the premium stuff have you heard of this
really old like it's an old herb of a
branch called quickly oh yeah they're
like oh yeah yeah so every Friday for
like eight years
I Drive by quickly after my piano lesson
and I would just get the Jasmine milk
tea with no ice like straight up yeah so
this is like like tighter childhood oh
yeah yeah I'm like a boba connoisseur
okay
[Music]
so I think I would start by just
teaching you guys how to make a classic
milk tea this is something that you can
get out like any boba shop they're
always gonna have it this is our version
of it and once you learn the basics of
this then you kind of make any kind of
drink so it's four parts there is boba
the tapioca balls or any other topping
that you want there is milk
I brought different types of milk for
you there is our tea we make like a
really strong tea concentrate and then
finally the sweetener if you were to add
a little sweetness yeah hey I'm really
curious about this so can you eat that
I'm happy you asked about it boba is
basically tapioca starch okay and so
tapioca is from the cassava root at our
Factory it comes as is tapioca powder
and we have to basically form it into a
ball okay and so it goes in this tumbler
and we missed it a little bit so it
starts to take shape and our stores
we're making boba on the hour every hour
fresh that is amazing and so but it
takes a really long last time it is 30
minutes to cook 30 minutes to cool and
then another 20 minutes of just sitting
our house-made syrup oh and so when it's
finally ready it has that perfect
balance you know that kind of that al
dente that cute cute so we're adding ice
to just really really chill it really
class and so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna shake it you want to make
sure you hold on to the top lit so it
doesn't go everywhere okay
[Music]
nice okay so that looks really good
what's you frothy shake it because it's
frothy and incorporates the syrup really
well and so when you drink it it's gonna
be nice and beautiful gosh yeah keep
going don't go over though okay
oh oh oh [ __ ] I gotta be more sure about
everything in my life
yeah and that's basically it
there we go make sure you get the Bobo
what do you think mm-hmm
how's the best photo ever had well you
like it there's that bounce the aldente
cute cute cute cute that's what we call
it that's what I mean ease call it that
is beautiful this is probably single
handedly like the best I feel you're
just saying that I want it
I don't know [ __ ] okay this is truly
truly delectable you guys well now you
guys know how to make it I feel like you
guys should battle I mean he's like a
bubble connoisseur she talks a big game
but I saw you shaking that dream
[Music]
all right let's get it oh my god
boba Bethel activated that's crazy
so regardless how do you get that brown
color is this sweet baby Ray's oh
interesting you're okay
[Music]
[Music]
synchronize
[Music]
is it frothing yeah that's beautiful
that's beautiful Rosia front than mine
[ __ ] it
oh here oh wow what it's like at 8:08
I love that [ __ ] alright you're hired
slowly you know I brought a bunch of
different toppings
we've got grass jelly and almond jelly
and egg pudding that we all make
in-house at but what guys
I even tracked down some of this you
guys recognized so like back home in
Indonesia they would sell a Stendhal
which is literally this it's like this
Street delicacy and they would just
sprinkle this stuff it's like green rice
flour jelly hopefully you guys can use
that in your drink and then we just
grabbed a bunch of other fun stuff I
didn't really have but go nuts it's
really fun
I see I see what you're doing out with a
strawberry and you know what we get pop
rocks so I'm just gonna use it to my
advantage
are you stealing my ideas well you stand
real close so you can hear those Oh what
the [ __ ] like at the top like in the
finish what are you like splashing onto
my face and [ __ ] and now I'm gonna have
some more scheana cherries are these
more scheana maraschino oh look at that
I'm adding two very fun gummy bears oh I
think you're chopping gushers is that
what that is
some white goo is coming out of it I'm
sorry
yeah it doesn't taste good but it looks
good Brian you almost done pencils down
I'm done
oh you're done today all right there it
is [ __ ] I have to reset my potatoes
[Music]
the concoctions if you will that we made
look amazing clearly but I feel like you
know we need like an unbiased judge
because you're you know you know what
you're not gonna like either of these
you know because you little make Bulova
for a living we need somebody that will
actually appreciate these yeah I think I
know just a person yeah exactly we have
Jojo outside actually so we're gonna
we're gonna gonna bring those out to him
so let's see what he thinks of it
[Music]
this is my drink
there's boba in there some matcha some
maraschino cherries and some fruit
gushers and worked really hard on this
drink and I really hope you know you
guys picked my drink especially you know
you Jody because we go way back and you
know we're on midsummer madness together
and I really hope you picked my drink
yeah I mean I get that but you know I
mean this like personal thing I gotta
like I'll taste Nicky's first and then
like maybe like like a stew it's early
but I hope ya know like that's not a
socks I'm just saying I hope I went you
know I mean I'm just expressing my
emotions and feelings here okay so oh
yeah sure I love you guys like yeah yeah
all right see what's he gotta say not
that mad yeah I was like ready to rip in
on it but it's not it's not horrible
hello this is my drink I call it the
strawberry short [ __ ]
it's like strawberry shortcake but with
a lot more personality and like pizzazz
you know so we have a black tea base cuz
I'm a purist and above a connoisseur and
I know my [ __ ] we did half-and-half
condensed milk some funfetti and some
gummy bears snuck in there oh and some
fresh strawberries to offset all that
diabetes and just to rectify this whole
situation just
I'm sorry hey you know hey wow I better
pay girls let's pretend that never
happened
well good please remain impartial all
right step out now bye thank you I see
you got a bit of the pop rocks first
smart woo one more time if you gotta get
the pop rocks dude oh wow yeah that's
pretty good that's that's pretty good
guys hey guys you know they were both
pretty fantastic we were actually really
impressed
thank you good job thank you we tried
them both we like them both but let me
comfort let me confer with Joji real
quick the final verdict
[Music]
I'm sorry Brian but I'm gonna have to go
with the pop rocks really yeah
congratulations yes it was the
strawberry and the pop rocks and the
cut-up strawberry bits inside right plus
you had a whole name to it yeah the name
was it yeah yeah I'm so sorry yeah
that's my song all right Brian
yeah I feel right okay good
can I get that hundred dollar back what
do you what $100 oh wait I don't know
we're talking about a dollar I don't
know all right guys great job
Nicky you're the winner congratulations
but you know what we should do we should
do one last game together okay let's
play this game called chubby bunny or a
but instead of marshmallows we're gonna
do boba in our mouths we're gonna make
it a little bit interesting so you got
to be able to say feast mansion all
right with all the Bobo balls in your
mouth and you guys for it there's a how
about how about we raise the stakes okay
well I don't know what do you guys wanna
play for the other loser gets drop from
the label go for it let's go ahh it's
show business
I'm sorry what
please mansion feast mansion I mean are
you yet Joey these management these
mansion okay we got a champ here
fusion winter oh he's got strategy
please ma'am clarity what about you
[Music]
face manager Lucy I think she sounds
best yours might actually volume-wise
you look like you got like a lot
choji's baby yeah okay all right mm-hmm
let's see it okay time all right guys
great job everyone hold up your cuts
let's see it lets see yeah compare let's
do like Brian you win on volume yeah
Nikki you sounded great though just the
tone the voice clarity judging or you're
you're a little quiet but you know you
held your own yeah that was if I spoke I
might I might throw up I think I think
you're that clear Victor Nikki cat again
Wow
yeah I know all right you guys so I am
the champ they [ __ ] suck you're both
dropped from the label yeah this was
beast mansion see you sometime greatest
cooking show the [ __ ] world baby
but we're on let's go
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in with a very
exciting hot sauce update our first ever
collaborative sauce it's here 88 rising
first we feast joining forces to make
dragon in the clouds
you saw me Joe G and rich Brian mixing
it up in the cauldron yuzu from Japan
etc I'm peppercorn from China and of
course you know your boy brought the
heat but don't worry we got some
professionals together to make sure this
stuff is FDA approved extremely limited
very quality and something lot we're
super proud oh if you want to get your
hands on dragon in the clouds visit 88
night market calm that's 88 night market
calm don't miss your chance the dragon
it can fly away
[Music]
you